so I mentioned your your Grammy
nomination so congratulations you were
just nominated again that's so cool you
you shot the music video I'm good on a
boat was that fun do you like being on a
boat I I get sick oh man it was like it
was it looked like very Grand the boat
looked really ground in the music video
it looked you know uh but it was old
boat and the like the Hydraulics or I
don't know what the proper terminology
is you were rocking so it was like so
bumpy and we were just like holding on I
have literally pictures of everybody in
my oh there I go yeah this is not what I
look like on a boat so but I'm yakking
off the side oh gosh yeah
um yeah everybody was like throwing up
and like it was crazy oh really oh yeah
I was like I was like so close to
throwing up but I like was like holding
myself I was like if I because you know
we when you shoot a music video you're
shooting the whole day you know it goes
yeah so I was like if I throw up now I
am going to be wait there's people on
the wall yeah
so we have people from all over yeah so
we during covid the whole audience was
actually screams like this and they
could tune in from Oliver and we thought
it was kind of cool
yeah yeah they're not vomiting which is
better right now yeah yeah tell them I
have ADD because I'm just like I am 100
the same way so I totally I went with
you squirrel
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]